tout le village ou presque est réuni
pour assister à l'événement il faut dire
que c'est un emblème de crécy qui
s'apprête à changer de visage c'est le
chantage c'est le repère c'est c'est
tout ce qu'on veut en plus précis
toujours été un défenseur du patrimoine
on est régi par une avarie
le souvenir de la marquise de pompadour
puisque c'est elle qui qui a fait cette
église qui a fait ce village perdurer
les gens sont assez attachés à cet
aspect culturel de mémoire de créer soit
la flèche a toujours penché
mais depuis deux ans la situation était
critique alors par mesure de précaution
l'église a été fermée et aujourd'hui
vaste opération de démontage
ça me touche parce que c'est quand même
un événement j ai gérard quand même dans
la vie d'une équipe et la vie d'un homme
c'est un renouveau je trouve ça bien
d'entretenir quand même le patrimoine de
la commune quoi il faut il faut pas
d'échafaudages c'est la grue qui entre
en action plus de 8 mai 2000 a soulevé
une fois déposé la flèche sera
découverte de ces ardoises puis démontée
et entreposés dans l'église la
particularité ici c'est que c'est une
des pauses conservatoire donc c'est
vraiment pour assurer la sécurité
souvent le fait dans le cadre d'une
restauration la dépose d'un clocher à 80
théret de pouvoir aller restaurer
correctement les structures qui sont des
fous l'objectif c'est bien de restaurer
le clocher les habitants espèrent qu'il
ne faudra pas attendre trop longtemps
mon père s'occupait d'église la ferme et
d'ouvrir le matin quand elle est restée
ouverte à l'époque où les aigles est
restée ouverte
c'est une belle église qui a une belle
acoustique qui est très bons éléments
qui sont classés aussi à l'intérieur
donc on espère aussi qu'un mécène
peut-être qu'il va nous aider il faut
réunir 500 à 600 mille euros pour
l'ensemble des travaux alors le village
appel à l'aide
une souscription est lancée